[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدموا من خلالها ابرز اخبار
وملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز
وعناوين اليوم
الرئيس الصيني يصل الرياض غدا في زياره
الرسميه ويشاركو في ثلاث قيمه من تستضيفها
العاصمه السعوديه
العربيه توصلوا جولتها مع الاسطول الخامس
الامريكي وترصد اليه التصدي لعمليه تهريب
الاسلحه
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه الرابعه كذلك
هيئه العلا واليونسكو تطلقني برنامج
الاستكشاف الحضارات في شمال غرب الجزيره
العربيه
مواجهه كاس العالم تشهد اليوم مواجهه
المغرب واسبانيا والبرتغال وسويسرا ضمن
دور السته عشر
حياكم الله يبدا الرئيس الصيني شيجن بنج
غدا الاربعاء زياره الرسميه الى السعوديه
وتستمر حتى الجمعه وذكرت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه ان الزياره تاتي بناء على دعوه
من العاهل السعودي وسيشارك خلال لها في
قمه السعوديه صينيه برئاسه الملك سلمان
والرئيس شيء ومشاركته ولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان كما سيتضمنه برنامج زياره
حضور الرئيس الصيني لقمه الرياضه الخليجيه
الصينيه والعربيه الصينيه للتعاونيه
والتنميه
هو تعليقا على هذه الزياره ينضم الينا من
لندن مساعد رئيس تحرير صحيفه الشرق الاوسط
ناس في زيد بن كمي ومن العاصمه الصينيه
بكين ينضم الينا اصبح في نادي رونج مرحبا
بكما معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض وابدا
معك سيد زيد ما الذي تمثله هذه الزياره
للرئيس شيء الذي تمثله للسعوديه في
توقيتها في دلالاتها السياسيه والاقتصاديه
كذلك
المشاهدين
زياره الرئيس الصيني في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايضا الحضوره هذه القمه همم
سواء القمه مع القمه الصينيه السعوديه او
مع دول الخليج او القمه مع الدول العربيه
همم تاتي في همم في الظروف الحاليه في ما
تشهدها ايضا همم يعني احنا بنتكلم عن همم
يعني العلاقات السياسيه لاصبحت الان همم
سؤال من جهه الغرب او من جهه الشرق ايضا
وهذا الصراع اللي صار بعد هذه الدول
واهميه المنطقه همم
واهميه المنطقه في السياسه الدوليه اعتقد
ان الرئيس الصيني زياره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وانا ايضا هي المحرك للدوله العربيه يعني
ليست فقط ايضا كذلك ان يلتقي ايضا قاعده
الدول العربيه الذين سياتون الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه احنا نرى العلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين الصين وبين الدول العربيه
ارتفعت ارتفاع كبير جدا خلال السنوات
الماضيه واصبحت الصين لاحاد الدول اللاعبا
في السياسه الدوليه المهمه التي تم
المنطقه وتم ايضا في حل القضايا التي
تعاني منها المنطقه سؤال في العالم او
كذلك في منطقتنا تحديد سيد نادر ما يهمه
لكن ما يهم ايضا في هذا الموضوع هو الجانب
الاقتصادي الذي ارتفع بشكل كبير جدا وصل
الى اكثر من 300 مليار دولار
في في الاهميه الاقتصاديه والاستثماريه
لكن سيد نادر همم قبل قليل همم سيد سيد
يتحدث عن ظروف دقيقه ربما حساسه همم يمر
فيها العالم بالنسبه الصين ما هي ال-
الفرص الهدف الذي يبحث ايضا عن الرئيس
الصيني في هذه الزياره التي سيشارك من
خلالها في هذه القمه الثلاث
اهلا ومرحبا بكم هذا الزياره والقمه تعتبر
معلما يعني تحمل اهميه كبرى لتدبير
العلاقات بين السوريين والسعوديه والعربيه
همم في هذا الوقت يعني تشد العالم همم
الكثير من الازمات وخاصه ازمه الطاقه
على الدول العربيه في
انتاجها وكذلك الدول العربيه كذلك هناك
حاجه الى الصين
همم المساعدتهم في
التنميه الاقتصاديه بس همم اكبر شركه
اقتصادي لدوله العربيه منذ سنوات وكذلك
هناك ايضا همم
حاجه من دول عربيه الى الاست مع التسعينيه
وتسهيل التجاره حره بين البلدين وكذلك
هناك ايضا همم امكانيه للتعاون في مجال
التكنولوجيا عاليه مثل الفضاء والطيران
وكذلك الطاقه متشدده في هناك الربط
لاستراتيجيه التنميه اللي في السعوديه
وكذلك لمباداره الحزام فريق من الصين
هذه القمم هكذا مستويات دائما ما تكون
السياسه هي من يغلب في هذه القيمه لكن هذه
المره هل تعتقد بان ملفات الاقتصاد ملفات
الاستثمار هي من ستغى على الملفات التي
سيتم نقاشها في هذه القمه
واحنا نعزلها لان الملفات الاقتصاديه هي
محركات محركات الدول يعني في التنميه
والازدهار هذه الدول الملف الاقتصادي هو
مهم جدا لهذه الدول ااه اعتقد ان الملف
الاقتصادي هو الاهم من اهل لانه ايضا
تاثيرات ايضا سياسيه على المنطقه في نموها
وازدهارها والمشاركه في المشاريع وايضا
كذلك في الاستثمار المشاريع فيها في الدول
العربيه انا ارجع من كل مثل المواضيع
الاقتصاديه او النمو المطارد في التجاره
البينيه بين الدول العربيه والصين يعني
وصل الى اكثر من 300 مليار دولار في
السنوات الاخيره تقريبا اضافه الى قيمه
البشاريع التي استثمرت فيها الصيني تجاوز
اكثر من 200 مليار طبعا من اهم الدول التي
لديها علاقه تجاريه بينها وبين الصين هي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لديها اكثر من
70 مليار او نحو 70 مليار تبادل تجاري
بينها وبين الصين اضافه الى المشاريع التي
ااا
تشارك فيها السعوديه والصين سواء كانت في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او تكون ايضا
بسيط احنا راينا في الزيارات التي تمت بين
القيادات السعوديه والصينيه سنوات الماضيه
واخر يمكن زياره الامير محمد بن سلمان
شهدنا توقيع عدد من الاتفاقيات التي همم
سوان في ما يخص الطاقه او ما يخص ايضا
البتروكيميكل او ما يخص ايضا كذلك التقنيه
والتكنولوجيا كل هذه الاشياء
هذه الدول الدول يهمها مصالحها بشكل اكبر
جدا وهما ايضا كذلك انا تكون ايضا في همم
راكب التنميه والتقدم والازدهار السيد
نادر بكين كيف تنظر الى تحول الاقتصادي
الاستثماري الذي تغيرت معه السعوديه من
خلال رؤيتها رؤيه التي يقودها ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان رؤيه 20 30 اي الفرص
التي تريد الصين ان تستثمر فيها مع
السعوديه او ان تقتنسها ايضا في هذه
الزياره
اه طبعا ارشحتنا يعني للتطور كبير
السعوديه بعد
الطرح هذه الرؤيه رؤيا 2030 وهناك
بمثابه السياسه الاصلاح في الصين فاتى
النمو نسبه النمو القويه للاقتصاد
السعوديه ايمكننا ان نرى خلال هذا
العام يعني نسبته النمو في السعوديه تحافظ
على نسبه عاليه فوق همم 10%
والسعوديه ايضا تريد
الاقتصاديه ليس ليس اعتماد على همم
[موسيقى]
الاقتصاديه والصين لديها الامكانيه
الجديده وهناك موارد الشمس
في السعوديه ايضا
خبرات وتقنيه لاستقلال الطاقه الشمسيه
وكذلك الطاقه النوويه
باستخدامها بشكل سلمي وكذلك هناك همم
استثمارات الصينيه يمكن ان تساعد على
السعوديه وتقنيه الصينيه يمكن ان تساعد
السوريين في الانتاج الخطوط البناء وخطوط
الانتاج المحليه لتصبح همم السعوديه
الدوله
هناك حاجه همم الى بعضها البعض وهناك اللي
امكانيه اللي تعاون وتحقيق فوز المشتركه
بين بلدتين طيب سيد همم
ايضا يبقى السؤال بشكل اوسع لان نتحدث فقط
عن السعوديه همم السعوديه ستستضيف ايضا
قمه خليجيه صينيه واخرى عربيه صينيه كذلك
هل ستكون برايك هذه الذين لاربما شراكه
استراتيجيه عربيه صينيه تقودها السعوديه
في المستقبل القريب
حقيقه عاشوا ان السعوديه هي يعني
همم التنميه في ال- ال- في الاقليم او
ايضا كذلك في الدول العربيه وايضا هناك
الدول العربيه ايضا هي دخلت في مشروع طريق
الحرير اعتقد يمكن نحو 20 دوله عربيه يعني
تكون مشروع همم طريق الحرير همم تشارك فيه
حتى الدول الخليج لكن همم
كميه العلاقات التجاريه او الاقتصاديه
التي همم بين الدول العربيه
من سنوات
مرتفع جدا وهذا دليل على ان هناك علاقه
همم جيده بين الدول العربيه
وبين الصين اضافه الى هناك يعني همم
في مصالح التي تبحث عنها هذه الدول تبحث
عنها اي تجتمع تجمع هذه الدول لتنقلها
ايضا الى علاقات استراتيجيه في المستقبل
واعتقد ان
السنوات الماضيه او كعلاقات سياسيه وايضا
اقتصاديه مع الصين اثبتت نجاحها بشكل كبير
جدا
وهناك ايضا رغبه من الجانبين
السعودي الخليجي العربي ايضا كذلك الدول
العربيه بتنميه هذه الشراكه همم بينها
وبين الصين سيد نادر هذه زياره تاتي بعد
انتخاب شيله ولايه ثاني في الصين تاتي
متزامنه ايضا مع تصريحات غربيه تريد ان
تضع العلاقه مع الصين في اطار همم معين
بالنسبه لهذه الدول وهنا نسال تشيء بعد
انتخابه لولايه الثالث هل تغيرت معها
اولوياته الخارجيه او لهويات العلاقه ايضا
شكل العلاقه كذلك دول الشرق الاوسط بشكل
خاص
اعتقد ان الصين الضاله يعني تقولي اهتماما
بالغلي تتغير علاقاتها مع الدول العربيه
ودور الشرق الاوسط
والدول الشرق الاوسط دائما تكون من اولويه
السياسات الخارجيه الصينيه فهذا قد اكدت
اكدت حسين همم
حاليا الرئيس الشهيد راح ايضا يتركه
البناء المجتمع مصر مشترك
علم العربي وكذلك هناك التنسيق ومواقف
متشابهه في الكثير من القضايا الدوليه
هناك دعم الدول العربيه الصين في ما يتعلق
بماسات تايوان
ومساله الحقوق الانسان كثير من القضايا
وهنا ايضا للا
في همم كذلك في ستار سياساته وقراراتها
المستقله وكذلك همم كل الاحتراف تتمسك في
عدم مبدا عدم التداخل في شؤون الداخليه
شكرا جزيلا همم لكما على مشاركه هذا
الحوار من العاصمه الصينيه بكين نصيحه في
نادي الر- وكذلك من العاصمه البريطانيه
لندن مساعد رئيس تحرير الشرق الاوسط
الصحفي السيد بنكمل
بعدها مرافقه الاسطول الخامس
من البحر الى البرد انتقلنا الى هنا الى
القاعده الامريكيه في المنامه
لنتابع كيف سجلت وما رصدت هذه المسيرات
المنتشره في الخليج العربي وكيف يتم
التعامل مع هذه التسجيلات التي ترصدها
سندخل الى غرفه التحكم هنا لنرى العلاقه
بين التسجيلات وطريقه التعامل معها
تابعونا
واشتراك
59 قبل 14 شهرا انه مختصه بتكنولوجيا
المتطوره لتحسين الامن البحري في المنطقه
فريقنا لا يتعدى ال 25 عنصرا لكننا نتحرك
بسرعه كبيره راينا المصيرات بالامس حين
كانت في المياه انتقلنا اليوم الى غرفه
القياده لنرى سيناريو محتمل لما يحدث حين
تصور هذه المسايرات تهديد محتمل على سبيل
المثال هذه احدى المسيارات وهذا تهديد
محتمل وهذه وجهه هذا التحديث ترسل الاشاره
عبر الانترنت
لعدد اخر من المسيارات التي قد تكون اسرع
على الوصول
وتطويق هذا التهديد المحتمل هناك اشارتين
او هذه الزوارق السريعه ترسل هذا التهديد
هذه النقطه الزرقاء هنا هو النقطه الزرقاء
هنا ل- اا اقتراب اكثر من التهديد المحتمل
وتنقل هذه الصوره بشكل اقرب لتظهر هنا على
سبيل المثال وكانها بارجه حربيه فبالتالي
يتم ارسال القوات البحريه
للاقتراب من هذا المكان بعد تحديد هذا
التهديد المحتمل هكذا تتم هذه العمليه من
هنا عبر الرابط بين المسيرات وبين الرجال
الذين موجودين في غرفه التحكم او على البر
للانطلاق لمواجهه هذه التهديدات في المياه
النرويجن الاول للامن البحري الاقليمي هو
ايران وتصرفاته المزعزع على الاستقرار
ورقينا امثله على ذلك كمهاجمه سفن تجاريه
في المياه الدوليه او تهريب مواد متفجره
من ايران الى اليمن نراقب كل هذه
التهديدات بشكل جديه وافضل طريقه للتصدي
لها هي عبر تقويه شركائنا بالمنطقها
وتطوير التكنولوجيا العسكريه وهذا هدف
الافق الرقمي
من القاعده الامريكيه في البحرين بديع
يونس العربيه
الرابعه
انطلاق النسخه السادسه من اسبوع مسك
للفنون بدورات المتخصصه وبرشا
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت وزاره البيئه
والمياه والزراعه في السعوديه عن منحي
مهله اضافيه لتصحيح اوضاع اصحاب محل تقليل
الملوحه جاء ذلك بعد ما رصدت الوزاره نسبه
مرتفعه من الاملاح في مياه الشرب كما شمل
القرار ايضا معامل المياه ومحل تنقيه
المياه في مختلف مناطق السعوديه
من احد مواقع تقليل ملوحه المياه بمحافظه
الخارجه انضم الينا مراسل العربيه هاني
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياضه اولا نريد
ان نعرف ما هو هذا المصطلح كيف تتم هذه
العمليه عمليه تقليل الملوحه في المياه من
حيث انت
نايف اهلا بك اهلا بمشاهدي قناه العربيه
طبعا هذا المصطلح الغير المالوف هو احد
تصنيفه التي صنفتها وزاره البيئه والذي
يعني هو محل مخصصه لتعبئه المياه اي الغير
مغلقه او الغير معبا ذاتيا كما هي تباع في
همم محلات الماركت والتموينات ولكن هذه
المحال وهي محال تقليل الملوحه هي ليج
المياه وكذلك التي او بعض الناس الذين
يستخدمونها العبوه الغير مغلقه مثل ما سوف
تلتقطعها كاميرا العربيه ولكن بينما تلتقط
كاميرا عربيه هذه المحطه سوف يكون ضيفي
اليوم المهندس خالد الخارجي وهو مدير
اداره المياه هنا او او مدير اداره وزاره
البيئه في محافظه الخارج استاذ او المهندس
خالد لو تتفضل معي هنا واليوم نتحدث عن
متابعتكم مراقبتكم للملوحه هلا هذا يعني
ان هناك مشكله كبرى في نسبه الملوحه
المياه في محافظه الخرج او المناطق
السعوديه
شاكرين لكم هذا اللقاء طيب لديهم شريحه
كبيره من المجتمع بالنسبه
للمحطات الملوحه تقليل الملوحه المنتشره
بمدينه الخارج
تخدم شريحه يعني كبيره من همم من الناس من
المحافظه
همم
للايفاء باحتياجاتهم اليوميه
طبعا المحطات هذه
خاضعه للرقابه والمتابعه من مكتب وزاره
البيئه والمياه في محافظه الخرج التي يوجد
هناك مراقبين يقومون بزيارات الدوريه لهذه
المحطات متابعه نسبه الاملاح
في المياه
اي عمليه لهذه المحال او كذلك المحطات
المياه هنا في محافظه الخارج لارتفاع نسبه
الملوحه كيف تقيمها يعني
همم
موجود والمتابعه همم القائمه من قبل
المرافقين الحمدلله لم نقص الارتفاعات همم
تخرج عن النسبه المحدده حسب القياسات
السعوديه للمياه التي لا تتعدى 500
بنسبه الملاحه عندنا النسبه تكون من ال100
الى 500
[موسيقى]
مهندس خالد يعني اليوم كيف تخيم جوده
المياه في محافظه الخرج وكذلك باقي مناطق
السعوديه يعني اليوم من خلال متابعتكم
يعني يمكن العقود الماضيه كانت السعوديه
تعاني من ارتفاع في نسبه الملوحه المياه
اليوم كيف نجدها يعني لا الحمد لله الان
ال- ال- همم الوضع تحسن كثير
وتطور بحيث ان المياه همم تحت المراقبه
والنوعيه تحسنت الى الاحسن
وانتشار محلات همم المياه والمصانع همم
نبقى نقوم بتجربه قليل كنت قاعد تعرفني
على احد الاجهزه هذه واحده من الاجهزه
اللي تستخدمها محال تقليل الملوحه وبعض
المحطات وهي اجهزه سريعه تكشف نسبه
الملوحات هذا الجهاز همم سريع جدا مجرد ما
تاخذ عينه من المياه مباشره قليل بس يسار
علشان توضح الكاميرا
ثواني وبعدين تقوم بتشغيل الجهاز بيعطيك
نسبه على طول بيعطيك هنا القراءه
المفترض ان تكون يعني القراءه همم الملوحه
العاليه الملوحه يعني لا تتعدى 500 ايوه
ايوه بالنسبه همم
جزء بالمليون ايوه فالان لما نقيس هذه
الان تحصل للمياه يعني جيده يعني معدلها
تحت الميه
يعطيك العافيه يا مهندس خالد شكرا لك هذا
اللقاء اذن اليوم وزاره البيئه وايضا
الفرق الرقابيه تقوم بكشف عن هذه المحاله
عن نسبه الملوحه التي كانت تعاني منها
السعوديه في العقود الماضيه في نسبه ملوحه
عاليه طبعا اليوم اغلب المحال مثل هذه
المحال وهذه المحطات الكبرى هي تستفيد من
الابار والمياه الابار وكذلك تستفيد من
المياه التي تدخها الجهه الرسميه والجهات
الحكوميه ل همم الامدادات الخاصه وتمديدات
الخاصه الى المنازل وكذلك هذه المحطات
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر انت واضيفك الكريم من
احد مواقع تقليل ملوحه المياه بمحافظه
الخرج مراسل العربيه نصفيه شكرا يعني
في الرياض بقدرت احدى الجمعيات بجمع فوائد
التمور وتحويلها لمنتجات ذاتعه عائده
اقتصادي ذات عائد اقتصادي واثر اجتماعي
وقامت الجمعيه بجمع حوالي 25 طنا في اطار
معالجه الهدر الغذائي وتحويل التمور لمنتج
متنوع الفائده
مبادره حديثه استطاعت من خلالها جمعيه
التمور في الرياض جمعه 25 طنا من التمور
الفائضه من المنازل وتحويلها لمنتجات ذات
عوائد اقتصاديه احد القضايا المهمه عندنا
وهي معالجه الهيدرو الفقد والفوائد
الموجوده داخل المنازل وهذه مشكله كبيره
عندهم ان كل ما جاء موسم جديد الناس تتعب
في
تصريف التمور اللي عنده الان حتى تشتري
جديد فديت الجمعيه المبادره تجمع هذه
الفوائد ثم تسوي لها عمليه تحويل جديد
لمنتجات اخرى سواء عجايين او اعلاف مئه
وثلاثون اسره منتجه استفاده من العجائن
حيث وصل عائد الدعم المادي للاسر المنتجه
الى اكثر من 28,000 ريال بينما قدر عدد
صغار مربي الماشيه المستفيدين بنحو 90
مستفيد من المسجلين في الجمعيات وقدر
العائد المادي لهم حوالي 36,000 ريال حيث
تهزف الجمعيه الى معالجه الهدر في التمور
والاستفاده من اعاده تدويرها
القطاع التمور قطاع الضخم في فرص كبيره
نحاول ان نجد هذه الفرص ونحولها الى خدمات
اجتماعيه وتنمويه وتفيد البلد بشكل كامل
بالشراكه مع اهل المصلحه من وزاراتها
وهيئات او مراكز او مزارع او صانع بحيث
اننا نرفع من كفاءه هذا القطاع ليخدم بشكل
اكثر كفاءه واكثر مسؤوليه
الاسره المحتاجه همم داخل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
ذات اثر اجتماعيا اقتصاديا لفئات المحتاجه
حيث وزعت الجمعيه اكثر من مليون ونصف
للمليون كرتون من التمر من الرياض اسامه
القاسم العربيه
اطلقت الهيئه الملكيه في العلا في
السعوديه برنامج الزمالك الدوليه في مجال
حمايه الاثار وذلك بالتعاون مع منظمه
يونسكو البرنامج الاول من نوعه في المنطقه
يعد فرصه
ويستمر لمده اربعه اشهر في العلب في بناء
القدرات ونقل المعرفه العلميه من خلال
تطوير المهارات الاساسيه في التراث
والحفظي في شمال غرب شبه الجزيره العربيه
في الرياض انطلق اسبوع ومسك للفنون بنسخته
السادسه والذي يتضمنوا برنامج الحافلا في
العروض الفنيه والمنتدى الابداعي بالاضافه
الى دوره متخصصه وورش العمل وسوق الفن
والتصميم الفعاليه السعوديه توفير فرص
للمبدعين بما يطول ممارساتهم والتفاعل مع
المشهد الفني السعوديه
من الرياض يلتحق بين مراسل العربيه وسام
القاسم اسامه مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض النسخه السادسه
لاسبوع مسك بلديه
ممارسته
اهلا وسهلا نايف تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
الساده المشاهدين بالتاكيد ينطلق اليوم
بالامس معرض مسك الفنون الذي يستمر لمده
اسبوع كامل بها عدد ايضا من وراء العمل
اضافه الى المنتدى الابداع الذي يحتوي عدد
من الجلسات وايضا الامسيات وايضا المسرح
الذي يقدم عددا من العروض الموسيقيه
والوصلات الغنائيه هذا المعرض يضم ايضا
عددا من المعارض تصل الى سبعه معارض واهم
منطقه في المعرض سوق الفن والتصميم الذي
يجمع اكثر من 80 فنان وفنانه كل فنانه
وفنانه له ركنها الخاص وله مكانها الخاص
يجمع فيه اعماله الفنيه للحديث اكثر عن
معارض اسبوع مسك الفنون سعود مع
الانستادين السلطان وهي الرئيس التنفيذي
لمعهد مسك الفنون اهلا وسهلا فيك اولا
معنا على النشاط الرابع حدثتيني اليوم كم
عدد المعارض الموجوده وكم يستمر المعرض
حياك الله سعيده بهذه الاستضافه طبعا احنا
عندنا مسك للفنون تم افتتاحه امس ومستمر
معنا الى يوم السبت يتميز اسبوع مسك
الفنون وجود مجموعه من الانشطه اللي تناسب
جميع الاغواق همم تناسب المجتمع الابداعي
تناسب الاسر تناسب الفنانين هل هو
الصاعدين زي ما ذكرت حضرتك احنا عندنا
مجموعه من المعارض الفنيه عندنا معرض
عزيمه واللي فيه احنا نتكلم على موضوع
الحنين
وحاولنا ان يكون همم معرض تفاعلي يكون من
اسمه فهو نحاول نصور العزيمه في السابق
ايضا في عندنا المنتدى الابداعي اللي بكره
باذن الله راح يكون الافتتاح له الساعه
5:00 مساء وراح يستمر لمده يومين يشارك في
مجموعه من المتحدثين المحليين والدوليين
يتحدثون على موضوع الفنون البصريه بشكل
عام ايضا في عندنا سوق الفن زي ما ذكرت
وسوق الفن هو منصه لتجمع الفنانين همم من
مختلف المناطق المملكه اللي عرض اعمالهم
الفنيه بالاضافه للبيع والتواصل مع
الجمهور
عن النسخه السادسه ما الذي يميز النسخه
السادسه من معرض اسمه المسك الفنون عن
النسخ الخمس همم التي مضت طبعا احنا
طالعين من السنوات السابقه بعد وضع وباء
كرونه وكان في خلنا نقول ان تقليص في بعض
الانشطه اللي يميز هذه السنه تمديد
الفعاليه اليوم اضافي بدل من خمس صارت 6
ايام ايضا سوق الفن
والمصممين رجع بشكل مختلف في عندنا ايضا
المنطقه للاطفال في عندنا مسرح زي ما ذكرت
حضرتك في يناسب جميع الفئات همم من
المجتمع ونتمنى من الجميع انهم يجون
يحتفون معنا بالفن والفنانين اليوم اكثر
من 80 فنان يجتمعون في هذه السوق كيف
تشاهدين اليوم وانت الرئيس التنفيذي
للمعهد كيف تشاهدين هذه التظاهره الفنيه
الكبيره التي بالتاكيد انها تعزز المشهد
الفني في السعوديه طبعا احنا لان احنا
يمكن رؤيتنا تنميه مجتمع مزهر ويكون الفن
متاح للجميع فسعيدينا احنا قاعدين نساهم
بشكل مباشر في تنميه قطاع الابداع
والثقافه في السعوديه بشكل عام وايضا في
الفنون البصريه بشكل خاص فاكيد همم وجود
مجموعه من الفنانين لعرض اعمالهم هذا يعزز
الانتاج الفني بشكل عام يرتقي بالضائق
الفنيه همم بشكل عام فكل هذه العوامل
تساهم في تحقيق ان شاء الله رؤيه 2030 في
ما يخص قطاع الثقافه والفنون
اذا انك تتحدث اليوم عن هذه التظاهر
الفنيه الكبيره جدا التي تعزز المشهد
الثقافي والفني في السعوديه يذكر ايضا هذه
المنطقه قد تم انشائها من العدم في غضون
ثلاثه اشهر لتظهر بهذه الحله الجميله
والكبيره جدا التي تجمع الكثير من
الفنانين والفنانات بعدد ورش عمل ايضا يصل
الى اكثر من 70 ورشه عمل تدريبيه المنتدى
الابداع الذي سينطلق قدنا بحول الله تعالى
بعدد من
حفلات وايضا الورش التدريبيه الكبرى
وانتقال اليك اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الرياض
مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم وظيفتك الكريم
رابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
مواجهته كاس العالم تشهد اليوم مواجهه الى
المغرب واسبانيا البرتغال والسويسرا ضمن
دوري ال16
وقف الرويلي مسنه السعوديه في محافظه طريف
في منطقه الحدود الشماليه السعوديه
احترفت على مدى اكثر من نصف قرن خياطه
بيوت الشعر والمنسوجات التراثيه رغم
فقدانها لبصرها منذ الولاده هذه المهنه
التي لا تخلو من التعقيد تستعين الرويلي
في ممارستها على حاسه اللمس فقط الزميل
الجزائر هذه القصه وافانا كذلك بهذا
التقرير
فتحات
[موسيقى]
يلا
اعمى عيوني
[موسيقى]
عارف بس صوتك هذا صوت ولد وهذا صوت تخاوي
وهذا صارت خالي
الله يا الله الحمد لله يعني يلا نفهم
قلبي يعني اشتغل بايديه بللم
حطناه في البيت
[موسيقى]
اي والله الله يسعدكم واتنا
ويقول لك الطيب مشكور الشيخ بيشكر يوم سمع
قرارك يا سيدي يا عزنا
نسير عند القصر القصير
احرار
نعمل بكل لسعود طيب من طيب الجدود نعمل
بكل سعودي
سلامتك
[موسيقى]
استدلاليه لمعرفه مواعيد دخول الفصول
والمواسم من خلال سلوكيات الابل وحركات
النجوم في السماء
[موسيقى]
علاقه العرب بالابل ونجوم السماء علاقه
استدلاليه وهم يستدلون على سلوكيات الابل
وعلى حركات النجوم على دخول الفصول
والمواسم افلا ينظرون الى الابل كيف خلقت
والى السماء كيف رفعت وهم يعرفون بدايه
البرد مع شروق نجوم سنام الناقه بالجهه
الشماليه الشرقيه قبائل الفاجر وهذه
المجموعه النجميه سلاما ناقه هي التي تدل
على نجم القطب المسمى عند العامه بناجم
الجدي الجدي خلوه فوق وارث المطيع
سهيل اليماني نمشي يلا على كلير وبالقدر
ناصل عقب عشرا
وثماني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام يبدا ميزان درجات
الحراره بالانخفاض التدريجي تباعا مع مرور
الايام وهذا اماره وعلامه على قرب بدايه
الشتاء والبرد الفعلي الجهاد لا يتحقق الا
اذا وصلت الشمس الى اقصى ميل لها ناحيه
الجنوب بما يسمى بالمنقلب الشتوي من 21
ديسمبر وطالع وحين ذاك تبدا تهب علينا
الرياح شماليه البارده ان الذي يرتدي شيئا
بهمته يلقاه لو حاربته الانس والجن تقصد
الى قمم الاشياء تدركها تجري الرياح كما
ارادت لها
السفن
[موسيقى]
يصل الرياض غدا في زياره الرسميه
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
العربيه
هيئه العلا واليونسكو تطليقان برنامج
لاستكشاف الحضارات في شمال غرب الجزيره
العربيه
مواجهه كاس العالم تشهد اليوم مواجهتي
المغرب واسبانيا والبرتغال وسويسرا ضمن
دور ال16
شكرا لكم المتابعه دائما العربيه دوت نت
لمزيد من الاخبار والمعلومات نهايه
الرابعه عوده القاكم يوم غدا في رعايه
الله
[موسيقى]